[Music]
do you ever feel that there might be
another battle playing out just beneath
the surface of the ones that we can see
in here a spiritual one I feel that way
well oscar-winning director William
Friedkin terrified the nation in 1973
with his film The Exorcist
now he's exploring the real thing Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo recently
interviewed the director about his new
documentary Raymond tell us about it
well the film is called the devil and
father a Mort now Friedkin started as a
documentarian Lord many years ago he
went on to do the French Connection of
course bill Blatt is the Exorcist in
many ways he comes full circle in this
project which examines the Rite of
exorcism and possession here's what you
can expect from the film five hundred
thousand Italians see an exorcist every
year
this woman is one of them her name is
Christina she said to be possessed by
the devil father Gabriela a morte has
been the Exorcist for the Diocese of
Rome for 31 years
he has exercised Christina eight times
without success this will be her night
some of this is genuinely creepy Laura
and it points to a real spiritual
phenomena i sat down with William
Friedkin to talk about the project and
discuss how it came to be watch this mr.
Friedkin forty-five years after the
Exorcist here you are back looking at
exorcism now you said I found this quote
from an interview I would never do
anything with demonic possession or
exorcism in it so why do this why do
this documentary now it was an accident
Raymond I was in the little town called
Lucca in Italy getting the Puccini prize
for my work in Opera I wrote to a friend
of mine who was a Catholic theologian
named Andre Amanda you know when I asked
him if he could get me a meeting with
either the Pope or father Mort and he
emailed me back immediately saying well
father and more is available would be
happy to meet you so I went to me and
father Mort was the lead Exorcist Rome's
Exorcist for many years three one three
hundred Exorcist yes his title was
Exorcist for the Diocese of Rome Wow and
you have met you had never seen a real
exorcism but you asked father amore to
allow you to photograph one he agreed to
let me witness one and I pushed my luck
and asked him if he would let me film it
not knowing what I would ever do with it
but he the head of the order wrote back
and said you can film it but alone with
no lights and no crew what did you see
this woman you call Christina that's not
a memory what did you see there her
entire personality changed she had
incredible strength that was way beyond
what she really had as a rather slight
woman 46 years old and her entire voice
and her nature and tone changed
completely during the course of the
exorcism mom what surprised you about it
I mean you you are credited with really
giving in the popular culture a vision
of what an exorcism looks like the
stakes and this battle between good and
evil is that what you saw in reality yes
but you know is the evil coming from her
or directed at her in my opinion it was
directed at her and I'm not sure why you
took that footage to neurosurgeons and
psychiatrists what did they tell you
there's the neurosurgeon said they had
no idea what this was and these were
guys who had done over 5,000 brain
surgeries each and they said while
everything originates in the brain this
is not a problem of her brain the
psychiatrist four of the leading
psychiatrists
in the country including the editors of
the dsm-4 and the dsm-5 the
psychological manual of Medicine they
now recognize exorcism they call it
dissociative identity disorder demonic
possession
how did it change in your understanding
of that mystery of evil or did it there
was no other explanation for what was
going on you know I always thought well
there's probably some medical or
psychiatric term for this there isn't
there's a psychiatric term for it that
involves possession so someone comes to
a psychiatrist and says they're
possessed they don't say no you're not
possessing here's some medication and a
little therapy you'll be fine
no they bring in an exorcist now which
they did it Columbia University where I
filmed these guys before I let you go I
was stunned to learn you only watch
Academy award-winning director
six to seven movies a year if why
because I've lost interest in what is
the current zeitgeist which is what
horror films to some extent but some of
them are good but mostly guys in spandex
flying around saving the world that
doesn't interest me Raymond always a
pleasure fantastic Laura 200-plus
exorcists our meeting at the Vatican
this week this movie opens this weekend
on the 20th it's available on-demand
April 24th
it is something just what a monster
talent legend but he and I agree on the
movies Mad Men in spandex and green
screens no thanks I'll watch the older
the Exorcist exactly thanks for having
fantastic interview